rivera we have learned that her family
said their final goodbyes to the former
glee star
as nyah's final tv project is revealed
actor and singer naya rivera that's naya
on season three of netflix baking
competition show
sugar rush which just dropped today
birds of a feather stick together my
friend
they do that's right filmed in february
the episode was dedicated to the late
glee star who passed away
just over three weeks ago in the waters
of lake pairu california
fans are prepping to hold a celebration
of life there tomorrow
e.t has obtained nya's death certificate
which indicates she drowned in a matter
of minutes
it also reveals the 33 year old was
buried at forest lawn memorial park in
l.a one week ago today
bury me and satin lay me down
on a bed of roses a source tells e.t
that naya's funeral service was quote
very small about 25 family members and
close friends including glee cast
members
now to singer tamar braxton speaking out
for the first time
since her suicide attempt i'm not
playing russian roulette with my life
anymore
perry what's your emergency my
girlfriend is not responding
two weeks after being found unconscious
at a downtown la hotel
tamar posted a lengthy message thanking
fans for their prayers alongside a photo
with her and seven-year-old son logan
the reality star then took aim at how
she was being portrayed on tv
quote i was existing for the purpose of
a corporation's gain
and ratings and that killed me headed
downstairs
just didn't work they've taken away her
happiness everything she held by
everything
that's tamar's boyfriend david in tears
when he called 911 the day of her
suspected overdose
tamar who starred on various wetv
reality shows for a decade claims quote
i was betrayed taken advantage of
overworked and underpaid
i wrote a letter over two months ago
asking to be freed from what i believed
was excessive and
unfair my cry for help when totally
ignored
that's it for me i'm out okay in a
statement week tv
says it will work with her
representatives to honor her request
to end all future work for the network
tamar says she sought treatment and will
now
utilize her voice to be an ally for
quote every black and brown person who
has suffered from the continued
exploitation
of reality television
[Music]